hey guys how's it going so I want to
share with you one of my new favorite
iPhone games it's called Bigfoot hunter
now if you guys are new to my videos you
might not be aware that I've actually
been hunting Bigfoot in real life I'm
Justine and I am a Squatch hunter and
I'm really excited because we've been
working really hard the past two years
to really increase our arsenal of
Squatch watching material we have all
new things and I'm super excited to
demonstrate it for you hopefully today
we'll actually get to see Squatch so
finding this game was extremely exciting
the game is pretty simple to play you
can play in two different ways you can
move your phone around to be able to
control and find the animals to snap
their photos or you can just swipe on
the screen to move it around but I
prefer moving the phone around like
crazy because it's a lot more fun and
interactive practice of the game is
you're hunting for Bigfoot and you want
to take a photograph of him but in the
meantime you're going to be
photographing a bunch of little critters
and wildlife to get coins and points so
that you overthought museum did you see
him I saw him as you progress through
the game you're going to be upgrading
your camera so that's why you want to
collect all these points and coins
because getting a better camera you'll
be able to photograph Bigfoot and get a
better photo of him he's near creepier
next quick recording oh you look great
oh I definitely got some good shots for
sure it'll develop your photos you'll
find evidence in all of this evidence
and photos you'll be able to collect
they'll put them in the museum so you
can check them out later but in the
meantime let's check out some of the
shots that we got a Bigfoot I'm gonna
say it with this one and this one and
they all saved your camera roll so you
can feel free to share those or send
them out later there's several different
places that you can go hunting on the
game there's Bigfoot National Park
there's melt
yet even Jarl and tumbleweed Plains and
last but not least sasquatch shores as
you get further along in the game it
gets a little bit more difficult so
let's roll up to mount Yeti Manjaro
and see if we can find ourselves a Yeti
no he's going ice at me the burn along
you go they throw things at you and
we'll also cloud your screen so like the
Bears will terr like honey at you and
you'll get poop thrown at you you have
to scrub it off of your screen No
Oh what did you know on my screen that's
disgusting stop it stop it I'm trying to
get my animals I'm gonna use a camera
bomb again okay holy moly
what are you doing get off of my camera
oh I tell the Eddie do you see him I
definitely saw him here he is he's
coming he's got it the thumbs go let's
go let's go
you will be mine I will get some sexy
shots of you prune juice I found some
evidence
I don't know how prune juice relates to
anything Bigfoot or Yeti but it doesn't
matter because any piece of evidence is
evidence to make a look at that it's a
little bit blurry and beautiful moving
along to tumbleweed Plains let's see if
we can catch ourselves some animals oh
wow you guys are hopping so high whoo
get him get him get him
talk about struggle jeez holy moly they
roll up and you gotta document where
I've gone to the cactus you know cactus
at me yum yum yum you up bring it on
okay well he looks great I did not do a
very good job but I'm gonna save them
anyway moving on to sasquatch shores oh
I gotta upgrade my camera you can
upgrade the number of shots your shutter
speed your reticle size
all right things are gonna get crazy cuz
this is I'm gonna get a couple of these
bombs some power-ups and a stun which is
going to be it fantastic so that I can
stun my creatures I'm here you will crab
dude they're so fast like they're
incredibly quick if you're not quick
enough you're gonna miss up
Oh ping he's so pretty oh gosh is my
favorite oh I found someone Bigfoot
evidence one of my favorite features is
the photobooth feature so you can go in
and you can take a photo of yourself you
can add stickers from any of the shots
that you've got so here we go here's a
little eat a little Bigfoot I'm like oh
hey girl hey add you on there and then
you collect stickers as you progress
through different levels so here's the
Yeti so many fun stickers and these are
all things that you collect as you play
the game and complete levels so I'm
gonna save it and I'm gonna post this on
Twitter so the hard work that you've
been putting into Finding Bigfoot there
is the museum so you can go in and you
can build different exhibits with
everything that you found but as you
continue through with all of the
photographs that you took you can build
these little setups for people to come
in as you so here's my Pacific Islands a
Squatch then I took photos of and they
will all look a little something like
this what's great is you can collect
coins of all of the people that come and
visit your museum because you're gonna
need those coins to upgrade your cameras
so I don't work for you guys is to take
some really cool pictures in the
photobooth app and tweet them to me post
them on Instagram and I will like those
as I see them coming through so I hope
you guys enjoy the game I'll put a link
in the description and I'm so freaking
excited because what I like most about
this is it feels like it's such an
interactive game because as you're
moving your screen you're kind of just
looking around and seeing the whole
world for what it is that's that I will
see you guys in the next video I hope
you guys enjoyed this and I look forward
to seeing your Bigfoot photos I'll see
you later bye